antonio sensatella on the mound today
for the colorado rockies well his first
outing of the year he beat the oakland
athletics eight to three he went
five innings pitched really well one and
two the pitch swag and a miss
got him with the slider good start for
senzatella just a dozen
pitches zach davies had some
very good success with the milwaukee
brewers he is
not a hard thrower and that'll do it
so he's going to try for his fifth
straight multi-hit game and his 12th in
the last 22 games against
the padres this is sharply hit the third
but garcia's there he'll go to second
for the fourth
out man left after a big knife no score
we'll get
will myers to the plate strike three
called on a fastball
myers looking for something else and
senza gets his first punch out
profar strikes out great job
back-to-back strikeouts three punch-outs
in the game for senzatella
daniel murphy leads it off for the
rockies pitch
is hit pretty well to right field going
back myers at the wall looking up it's
gone
just got over the out of town scoreboard
daniel murphy with his first homer of
the year
and the rockies take a one to nothing
lead good pitch right at the knees for
strike three on the first strike out of
the day for zach davies
and a swing and a miss so that's that a
couple of strikeouts so walked it meant
nothing but the lead home run
tall left-handed batter grounded out on
the first pitch he saw
dahl swings at an inside fastball loops
it into shallow left center field coming
on tommy pham
and the left fielder will get there to
make the catch here's a two-two to story
it was down and he grounds it to the
left side garcia at third base today
with machado d-h and makes the play
and the throw to first just in time to
get story two away
in the year to left field struck pretty
well fam going back
onto the dirt of the track to make the
catch and a one two three third for zach
davies
so here's matt kemp the d.h he homered
last night but grounded out to third and
is only at bat so far this afternoon
pitch to kemp swing and a high fly ball
left field
back into the corner goes fam over
and out of here matt kemp his second of
the year on consecutive days
and the rockies lead three to nothing
third baseman today greg garcia
swaying and a miss on a high heater
that's another strikeout for senzitella
number four for antonio this is
a hot pop-up to ryan mcmahon
the single doesn't bother antonio sends
it to a middle of
five senzatella has found his groove no
doubt about it as he starts the sixth
inning of work
fires to right this one is driven to
left center dog going back can't catch
it
over his head it will one hop the wall
cronenworth is headed for second base
maybe third he's taking off for third
he'll get there standing
so a triple for jake cronin worth here
to lead it off in the sixth inning
swung on and missed a strikeout again of
tatis
that's the fifth of the ball game for
antonio that'll bring up grisham
and he strikes out grisham back-to-back
strikeouts with the curveball drew and
now
cronenworth at third base to score needs
a two-out hit
this one is lined to left field and it's
gonna one-hop the wall from third base
comes cronenworth
as machado is headed for second base
throw goes there and manny
will get in safely an rbi double for
manny machado and the padres are on the
board
two on for san diego with two outs and
this
[Applause]
and the padres settle for one here in
the sixth
san diego trailing in the rockies three
to one
lefty lefty here to ryan mcmahon the
second baseman another 2-2
hit the center field starting in was
grisham now going back at the wall
it is gone touch him all time for ryan
mcmahon
his first of the year and the rockies
are up five to one
runner at third with one out for david
dahl who swings and lines it down the
left field line that's a base hit
in comes owings and the rockies lead six
to one here in the seventh
guerra comes to the plate swing and a
high line drive
down the down to left field and that
one's gonna bang off the wall
one run scores another one comes in and
the rockies have blown it open they lead
it eight to one and
this is up the middle murphy he's gonna
have a leg hit he's four for four
blackman coming home
9-1 colorado it'll get machado
to the plate inside out swinging a bloop
to right field that fallen fasted in for
a hit
here comes tatissa round he will score
it's another rbi for manny machado bases
are loaded with two outs myers coming up
myers drives one to right field down the
line towards the corner and it's going
to be off the wall
and this could score three runs as myers
is headed for third base he will get
there with the bases clearing triple
padres have the lead off man on third
base
ground ball right side mcmahon will go
to first for the out
as the runners score in the back door
from third comes naylor
and it's now 9-6 manny machado
is the hitter grisham at second with two
outs
in the air to right field this should do
it charlie waiting
charlie's got it and the rockies improve
to
6-2